all of us are moving towards more
virtual communication
that is a shift in context that's going
to change the way people understand you
the way people experience you you cannot
engage in exactly the same behavior and
assume that you're going to get the
exact exactly the same results the
context shifts it's been more than a
year since we went from spending time in
meeting rooms and long commutes to
meeting over zooms and accidentally
staying on mute
as gsb associate dean brian lowry just
implied we need to adjust our
communication and presence to make sure
we get the results we want
my name is matt abrahams and i teach
strategic communication at stanford
graduate school of business
welcome to this quick thinks episode of
think fast talk smart the podcast
in this episode we're bringing you some
of the best advice we've received from
guests on how to be more successful in
your professional and personal life when
communicating virtually
attention is the most valuable commodity
we have in the world today
more valuable than money more valuable
than bitcoin and even more valuable than
game stop stock
when communicating virtually you need to
work hard to both gain and maintain
attention and focus
it's all about being relevant and
engaging
here are a few tips from professors tina
selig bob sutton and sarah sewell
on how to keep your audience
interested
i think it's really important to change
up activities really quickly like every
10 to 15 minutes i almost feel it's
almost like sesame street you know every
10 to 15 minutes you need to change
you're watching a video to doing an
activity to
breaking into small groups you know
folks get bored looking at a screen if
things are static so you need to plan a
lot in advance i view myself as more of
a producer
when i'm planning an online class
there's a tremendous amount of thought
that goes into essentially scripting the
whole experience
[Music]
i think we're all struggling in this uh
journey together the first thing that i
would start out with and this is for
those of us who are teachers who are
executives and also just having control
of our calendar
is that uh is that
for emotional and cognitive reasons
we've got to
pace ourselves and encourage people to
pace one another so this means the
meetings have to be shorter this means
there has to be breaks this means um and
some of the folks of the design school
are really cool about this consider
doing 35 of your meetings audio only
[Music]
so as educators i think we have to find
ways to reduce cognitive overload
so for example i now offer my
information in much smaller pieces
interspersed with breakout groups or
synchronous work and shared documents
that's one of the tricks that i've been
experimenting with
i've also been working to make my slides
more visually appealing and much less
cluttered and this is where i've had the
opportunity to watch you teach
frequently on slide design and this has
been very helpful to me oh thank you
presence is also critical to success
when communicating virtually we need to
be able to
connect to our audiences not just
through our words but also through our
nonverbal behaviors
here are my favorite quick tips from
carol robbins professors christian
wheeler and jennifer ocker and lecturer
naomi bagdonis on how simple and slight
shifts in your presence can help you
connect more authentically with your
remote audiences
the fact is that it's
i think we've become much more
transactional as a result of the
pandemic
and much more task oriented especially
in business
at the expense of relationships so we
have a lot of contact maybe but not a
whole lot of connection
and if we want more connection then
we've got to make a little bit of time
to ask each other how are you really
doing
[Music]
one thing that organizations need to
think about is ways to artificially
induce that into this more formal zoom
style interaction that we've adopted
so in my in my exercises what you know
what we do is we have people engage in
exercises where they're interacting with
one another they're experiencing this
positive affect and they're engaging in
some degree of self-disclosure which is
something that creates the foundations
of trust
[Music]
it used to be that leaders needed to be
revered
and now they need to be understood
and all the while you know humor is
particularly potent alexa for for trust
and when we laugh with someone be it in
person or even over screens through zoom
the bottom line matt is giving birth
having sex and laughing with colleagues
in zoom meetings are actually have a lot
in common
um we're building trust and no one's
wearing pants there you go
technology has allowed us to connect
like never before as so many of us work
from home but as we all know technology
can really make or break how we're
perceived and how we get our messages
across
use these straightforward tips that i
share with my students when you use zoom
teams meet or any other virtual tool
how you show up really matters make sure
you fill up half the screen with your
face and upper body
make sure there's a little bit of room
between your head and the top of your
box check this out before you actually
join the meeting
you have to be well lit too
as human beings we read a lot on
people's faces and if we can't see your
face if you're covered in the shadows
like you're in the witness protection
program it makes it hard for us to trust
you be well lit and fill up the screen
you also need to make sure you raise
your camera up so it's right at your eye
level
so it looks like we're looking directly
at you when you're speaking to us
and make sure you look at that camera so
it looks like you're looking at us as
we're watching you
making eye contact is critical for
building connection and trust
i take a picture of my family who on
most days i like and i tape it right
behind my camera so i'm looking at
people i care about
as i present that draws my attention to
the camera and can be really helpful for
connecting
variation is also critical in your voice
if people are monotone or their rate
stays the same we lose focus and
attention we are designed to pay
attention to things that change and vary
so make sure you vary your voice a great
way to do this is to add emotive words
adjectives adverbs descriptors we tend
to inflict our voice as we say those
make sure also that you gesture now
gestures are different when you're
virtual you need to make sure your hands
are up and visible in the box that means
keeping your thumbs about at your
shoulder height and always make sure to
gesture slightly beyond your shoulders
not so far that you go out of your box
but you don't want your gestures in
front of your face or your chest it
makes you look
tense and tight
finally when managing interaction like
conversation during a meeting or during
a q a session
leverage paraphrasing paraphrasing is a
tool that helps you signal that you've
heard what somebody said but it also
allows you to interrupt and interject
simply highlight or summarize something
somebody has said and then add your
opinion and link or bridge to the next
topic
taken together working on engagement
presence and how you can maximize your
remote tools setup you can enhance and
hone your virtual communication
taking the time to work on these skills
will serve you well because while we're
all excited to return to more in-person
communication interaction
virtual communication is likely here to
stay
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
produced by stanford university's
graduate school of business for more
information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu
find us on social media at stanford.gsb